what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation I see you you see me we're
gonna watch a movie called I see you how
did we stumble upon deciding to react to
this well it's a horror movie and we've
been loving covering horror here and
it's number one on Netflix I was like I
don't know what this Phillips I've never
even heard of it it's not a Netflix
original it's an actual movie that made
its way to number one so we said we're
watching it today who knows maybe it'll
become a segment where we're just like
what is number one on Netflix let's
watch it ladies and gentlemen if you can
see us please go ahead and leave a like
you know you'd love to do that also
subscribe and click the notification
Bell because we covering more movies
these days as always full length
Reaction watch along three sync up with
your own copy available for super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page thank you
all who joined we got so much crap over
there that you would love to fill your
minds with crap Galore is what we call
it and I think that's all all right
let's watch this and see what's going on
thank you for being here
[Music]
ah Dairy d-e-r-r-yah
damn this kid does his own stunts yeah
he trained a long time for this actually
Insurance almost wouldn't let him do it
watch out for Bears my dude oh cool shot
yeah
whoa
gnarly geez
I love this I don't even know what this
is a Rotten Tomatoes
[__]
sounds like a Trent Reznor score
this movie is weird
I love it so far
is that Helen Hunt
is it I don't know I can't tell I can't
tell either
do you need money for school
do you want to connect with me as a
person here's a hundred fifty dollars
get yourself a hot lunch so when you
start sleeping on the couch
keeps on passing out in front of the TV
not that I blame you
mom's a [__] so are you getting into
fights now
they're being [__] that's no excuse
don't defend yourself to have the other
kid alone
the other two kids
one of them cried
it pooped his pants
good audition scene
both of you
I already I'll see you later
that's my name whoa is this like your
marriage whoa
is like my marriage are you kidding me
I thought we got bulletproof windows I
thought we installed the three inch
thick ones
oh you on my lemon drink did he put the
mug up there
yeah just a spider you're an addict
10 years old went missing on a bike ride
last night near Jupiter Park just
letting Michael came Michael King was
abducted cycling to a corner store in
the city not Michael Kane
you lead on this
got it
not Roadmaster any longer
I feel like there's a like a large
demonic presence it was like an
overlooming shots they keep happy like
Zach thought yeah it's like if you took
the Evil Dead POV and just made it
really ominous and slow in just
everywhere
it's literally like something is closing
in yeah
oh what a messed up ghost
it's like the camera's a character
just a window repair man I'm not gonna
hurt you
I'm sorry who let you win a kid of yours
very polite you you trained her well
who
I would not just uh let that go yeah I
would follow that guy outside
I want answers I went fast I want to
know where that kid sleeps I wonder
where he eats or nobody gets his bike
wheels from
Jesus Christ
sir should we bring it in
yeah you can uh
you can beg
wow there hasn't been a pocket knife in
this town in 30 years
you remember cool Gardens before you're
taught oh of course I remember the green
knife or Gordon is yeah I got help put
in that he ain't good now
so what do you think
copycat
foreign
that with a plastic fork little girl
little girl ghost could be who died yeah
yeah Green pocket knife girl ghost
screw repairman okay you're angry how
could you do that answer the question
oh you don't get to call me that you
think pancakes and fancy dinners are
gonna make it up no you ruined our
family and you should [__] pay for it
well
our nine-year-old Michael King went
missing just
okay that repairman they sent out I
think he stole from us you what all of
our silverware is completely gone he
said something strange about some girl I
don't know what's wrong with him
he's not that sudden me for cheating
he's upset about the boy what that
repair man stole the photo
ironic artwork
Ambien that helps calm the anxiety hey
how'd you get in here
where are you going
oh there's something terrible about to
happen to this animal come on
I heard you
whoa Wowie
yes but let me out now
Connor
that's not Connor it's unresolved trauma
heard pounding so I came up
he's out
I have no idea what's going on in this
movie you know it's like all the tropes
with none of the traditional tonal build
up yeah I have no clue I know you can't
just forgive me
but I want you to know I'll do whatever
it takes to make did you want to get
married
you really think we'd still be together
if you hadn't gotten pregnant
I'm trying Greg
it's hard being a Greg seems like it man
I had no idea what you had to deal with
whoa
a little late to be playing video games
isn't it it's a little late to be
cheating on tattooses
what in God's name is that
night
she has a weird false reassuring way of
delivering her lines
hence the counselor manipulating you but
yeah I feel like she's not actually
saying what she's really feeling
[Music]
what is what is happening in this movie
like stuff's Just Happening
whoa
bust out them rubber sheets that's
embarrassing you're a drunk cold gourd
emo was an exact match of a serial child
abductor you put away 15 years ago
you said what they still had on hand
Jesus I sent Larson to track down the
two boys that escaped Braun and Travers
but they might remember details now they
could help him beat Gordon's defense I
interviewed both those boys extensively
when it happened why'd you end up with
us Ray
huh he got too close to the truth Tommy
Tommy
absolutely terrified of these tummy guy
he ain't never been the same I still
have that brontosaurus you gave me
whoa
no no no no no no no no no
what
how is this all together
this is a secret Slenderman movie or
something
after the little house just the magic
house
it means
you're never gonna find him
ugh
are they living in the magic house they
must be
I'm still not sure if this movie has
these what is happening whoa
hey what are you doing dude it's Sam
Merlot
last time because that was a whole
different because I'm in love with you
oh no no God I don't want to be with you
scared Todd stop what we have you know
whoa I was gonna say where's Connor at
God
you're the worst kind of person to have
an affair with loud and show up yeah
no discretion whatsoever you want to get
caught
ow ow ow
ow careful
something about the walls
as soon as Connor goes to school I think
I should take you to the hospital
this is a terrible situation yeah he's
gonna stab him with that toothbrush
kid plays every moment like I'm in a
horror movie
[Laughter]
how else would they know how to feel
you're calling me
did you leave your phone somewhere
oh
uh
get in the car
I'll be right there
someone's in the house or something and
they're killing children and leaving
pocket knives
you can tell me I won't be mad I just
wanted
wowie I'm so sorry my son is out there
Greg is going to find him go Greg
got this keep that stapler close
Michael watches out his childhood window
what are you looking for oh
that was scary yeah chances are I knew
the kidnap
he grabs him
drops one of the knives to throw us off
maybe
solid Theory or
stops the kit
no one's found that yet
this is so well hidden
so well camouflaged
sorry it took so long I didn't
yes
a complicated situation of being
classic jump scare
explained that we were over and out of
nowhere it just fell why didn't you call
an ambulance
I don't know that
so angry he tried to kill someone
no no you don't get to lose it right now
do you know
what will happen to our son
I won't be able to protect it you gotta
take the fall for this I the body put a
green pocket knife on it go change out
of those clothes
um
this is fascinating there's like two
very definitive different
stories happening here and they both
feel equally Bleak and yet somehow so
disparate and detailed yeah and I'm like
how is this connected exactly other than
the characters
Good Fellas
nice practical lighting for an ominous
tone the movie has really good music
yeah they even insert like a slight
child voice there like a little giggle
or something yeah like little echoes
oh the photos are gone did you see that
whoa what
I was so engrossed by the the shapes of
everything but yeah that wall is
completely blank damn
silverware oh is it all in her head
is it that movie or his head it's always
one in one of their heads
oh
that's very human barrier
yeah the grab a shovel and help me or
hop in
I feel like I should know it
I don't know frogginess
is this like a furry thing but for
amphibious types
what like living in the walls
hey Connor
you want some pancakes
so they were actually under the bed yeah
well it can't be in all their heads
because they were gone
sure this this makes more sense let's
send a kid's head it could be he was
there the whole time so
foreign
holy [__] whoa
oh no
stop for anything I'll call you when I'm
on my way mine's Jackie I've gotta find
the son of a [__] who did this drive
watching you even now damn this is a
great streaming movie yep
perfect for Netflix and chilling yeah
I see you to hang those back up
why'd they take all the photos that was
for us the audience
make a lot of noise
and you can't really call for backup in
this situation because you'd have to
explain where you were
that's mean
foreign
symbolize yeah I'm like is it one of
their songs is it the themes of the
lyrics
[Music]
yeah you gotta get him out of the street
to defeat him
no turn around
he doesn't deserve to die no he doesn't
deserve this
oh
interesting nice cut
okay
and now it's a VHS movie
go IndyGo
it's a fridge what the hell
never seen a fridge before
they actually ex-military is that just a
military bag
you gotta be kidding me
I'm not
are they also killing the kid
what I just doesn't try to connect I
feel like this could be a red herring
this is loud
oh interesting
[Music]
so so this is like only worth it for
this part of the day
quick
I can't see anything night vision
so turned on right now
[Music]
Nice Nice Shot this movie's got nice
restrained drone stuff
it's like a weird rashamon that this guy
overstayed is welcome
fun at all
I know the word
oh
catch up to you BJ oh yes sir yeah
that's actually that fits perfectly
they see the Book of Revelations
happening outside
that'll rain
you idiot
bastard seven-letter word starts with B
hmm
mission accomplished there's so many
places to hide your down there if we
need a Quick Escape that's our route yes
I care about that wouldn't it be kind of
funny to mess with them take some random
[__] make them think they're going crazy
two days this guy went crazy
she really took the assignment to Heart
just a second just let him in he doesn't
know you don't live here and then she
became an accomplice on top of already
being a criminal
oh what'd you put in the pills
dude I would have bailed on this with
this kind of guy yeah just leave the
house now don't even tell him
her kid got swiped last seen wearing a
green soccer jersey went missing in
Troubadour see one of the kids who
survived or something
come on
I'm not gonna hurt you
Connor
you mean to tell me when Helen Hunt came
over here she wasn't like why is this
door locked with this with a freaking
hockey stick yeah you failed to mention
that part
[Music]
oh okay okay
oh God
oh my God
sicko
[Music]
that is too far man yeah
as
it was odd
and what's the point
I mean it
please you gotta ditch this guy you
should push him off the roof okie dokie
maybe she'll just bail right now she's
got to be the one who's warning Connor
though
you do what yeah leave
wrong choice of words you should have
just left
he should have just left
it's cleverly orchestrated the way they
did this uh
no
what
no what are you doing
Jesus oh I wonder if you go back and if
it was in the shot yeah probably I
wonder yeah if you can spot them in in
various moments maybe yeah
yeah
that's clever
how does she end up hitting him we're in
this together now yeah or is she just
gonna witness this
yeah
just messing with their sanity man
[Music]
twist upon twist
wow
oh my god oh that's gnarly oh [__]
everyone's kind of fighting this woman
movie got me there yeah me too that's
good
that's that is a solid development
that clinches a lot of things I think
so is he the guy with the green pocket
knives then
wait was it their stuff that he just put
in the trunk like they get it was his
maybe she had like a like a camo what
did you put in the trunk that might just
have been a different duffel bag with
the bat in it sorry it took so long I
wasn't
oh my God why didn't you coordinate
those
why didn't you call an ambulance
imagine having all this knowledge
the worst position
Barbara really came for her
it's hilarious
damn
[Music]
what's up with this guy there's like a
sadness is he like the evil twin that
they separated at Birth I mean like he
has a personal motive against the family
and maybe I mean that that's my
convoluted Theory my other theory is
just like maybe he's got some weird
family trauma that this is bringing up
or something like he kind of like almost
crying
[Music]
get up there's so much going on in this
house
no I am not gonna let you ruin just for
free
oh yeah oh damn it that
it's this house
come on look at button button keys
always in such close proximity
[Music]
he's like punishing this guy
no
oh God and to wind up with him
she must think he knows
this is so convoluted but I wouldn't
happen any other way
this is so cost so stacked with [__]
right now
it's an overlapping Venn diagram
horrible human nightmares
of course
he's the guy so he is the guy yeah
why would he be doing it I don't know is
a serial killer
I would just be like on the ground
no hello
hello can you hear me
you're becoming dumb stop put as much
distance between you and that car as you
can
don't go toward the light
perfect opening
foreign
so you can see down the hole no no
help
us
oh it's them
it's gonna be okay come on
no I liked you I know it's not my type
so I'm taking it back to town
it's going to be edited and everything
yes
[Music]
you weren't concerned when your kid was
kidnapped
who's copycatting in my own damn house
that's interesting you are I was scared
for him like 40 minutes ago yeah I was
scared of him other guy's pretty awful
but damn and now I'm just hoping that
this guy maybe steps up and takes him
down he's gotta have some connection to
this yeah it's probably like someone's
brother wake up
everybody should put a little makeup
all I need you to do is stand up okay
treated like an intruder
just stand up
don't do it
needs to make it look like he caught an
intruder
now it's a Vengeance movie yes the woman
I thought I killed was killed
me yeah
[Music]
there was an ax in the garage
yes
assume your final form
[Music]
consequences man
do you have another gun
almost Devil's Rejects like
yeah and then the flip-flop between
who's who's the real bad guy yeah who's
gone too far for real
where is the line
squatters man
it's like the less tortury version of
The Collector
it's a fun experiment in perspective
this movie it's a fun ride
led by Helen Hunt
in her finest role yes
opposite not quite Dennis Quaid
[Music]
come on
come on Frogger oh
do it for the kids
oh
because he chose the house too right
yeah
come on Frogger come on buddy
[Music]
come on Helen Hunt walk in nope up not
be done he done
come on you got one more twist up your
sleeve stick The Landing don't make me
hate this it's more like a Saw movie no
yeah in some ways this really reminds me
of the collector which is itself is and
he came here to terrorize Elite
detective on that case she tied up his
son
he was gonna be next I stopped you just
in time
he shoot me you're shooting a cup you
have any idea what's coming for you
please be recording this
please
yeah he was a victim
you don't understand
huh
when I was a little boy wow
oh no
whoa that was a shoulder clip right I
believe so
oh my God he was an undercover cop
here's my bachelor
observing this man for months on end To
Catch a Predator
[Music]
oh he got rid of the bull oh yeah I was
like please no
[Music]
put the raw Man Behind Bars
see you had every right to cheat on him
Should Have Cheated it was good that you
did
[Music]
foreign
yeah the jersey and all that
it's a little bit like prisoners too
let's not give
something I want to say it's High
Caliber no not as much of a film
otes
wow
[Music]
his hair was black
Yoshi
he always had the Yoshi yeah
fun
last line is Helen Hunt going what the
[__]
faster black
don't just think because Dad's a
cellular killer I forgive you for
cheating
laughs
it's a principle that counts
yeah where did this come from and why
didn't I hear about it how did he get so
big
what's going on we're gonna look up some
stuff box officemojo.com this movie make
any money
was it released in theaters
um it made like a million dollars okay
um not a lot
but it's good to see that it's like
picking up on streaming I mean it's like
a perfect movie to see on stream yeah
yeah totally all right before we look at
the Rotten Tomatoes score for any of
this yes um no I enjoyed it it it
started off in a way that was like okay
this feels like one of those low budget
mystery thriller movies I can I can feel
the restraint on budget and they're
doing more with their camera work
and as much as I was enjoying it because
it had a bit of not as
ugly or nasty but it still had
like I haven't seen collector um but
I've I've seen all the Saw movies and
collector is about a guy who breaks into
a house because he's desperate and then
finds out that it's a Serial Killer's
house in there basically like Saw traps
inside like the song the team who took
over Saul wrote it and directed it oh
okay yeah well this movie
um
I was like all right I'm not sure it did
a great job in the first half of it of
okay is this like an immediate
real crime Thriller
is it Supernatural like I couldn't tell
what was happening because it was so
questioning of how is the the story of a
of a of a family with this affair
situation and this cop who is coming off
the heels of dealing with this affair
now investigating this mystery of a
missing child
tying into whatever crazy Shenanigans
are happening at home
um and then they did the thing where it
uh they changed plot they changed right
and I was like okay hold the Barbarian
now we're seeing it from the perspective
of the people who have been living in
the home
and at first I was like interesting and
then I started going well maybe this is
not as it's kind of undercutting some of
the attention then it just started
getting [__] crazy yes and then it
started getting like really then then we
reached impressive like I it was a
combination of this is ridiculous to
this is impressive yeah because once
they laid out that especially the fact
that it is purposeful why this guy is
here because they're pitching him as
he's the serial killer they did a really
good job on uh when I said when a
reference Devil's Rejects of making you
go ah they're the victim no wait they're
the bad guys I don't know who to fear
for yes I don't know who to root for I'm
actually working for the bad guy now uh
he was in a bag he actually wasn't a bad
I mean he's unnecessarily torturing the
rest of the family but that is to
torture the main guy yeah of course to
torture the cop
um which I thought was great it had a
real cool mood I mean like a bigger
budget they probably could have allowed
this to be more of a dread heavy film
sure you know like I think that was it
when you're saying prisoners I was like
yeah it was a little bit more like
deliberate and Dread heavy and or this
was moving like this moves fast yeah
it's it's enticing though like the whole
movie is enticing and it has a really
great like what the hell is going on
factor to it and then when they and I
like the midpoint of it because because
it's like we're telling you what's going
on but there's so much more to uncover
yeah as it keeps going and I thought
that was great because I thought ah
you're revealing it a little tour early
and and then they because like even when
the girl dies
um oh when he thinks he killed his
friend yeah
uh he seems concerned it's not like he
just snapped you know yeah he's not
completely immoral yeah so I think the
last half of this movie is like very
impressive on how they handled it
because it does whenever you think the
movie's done telling you it's tricks and
as you're just watching you know the
answer you're like oh no there's more
there's more to discover about the
reveals right up until the very end
um so yeah I mean like because you were
saying you said like you feel like
there's something more personal with him
and I was I didn't quite pick up on that
right away
but when you said that it made me go
maybe he's one of the victims yeah and
so to see
uh so it was a good tag team effort
there in the mystery well done with well
done but the but but yeah I thought it
was I thought it was well done I thought
it was really well done
um would have liked some type of resolve
with Helen Hunt's character
and the child because that is the first
half of this movie and then they kind of
just go
well she learns that's done yep and uh
there's just gonna be left to pick up
the shards of their broken lives I guess
yeah because it it's it's more I I
thought it was I was really looking
forward to seeing how this all pays off
yeah you know
um because I like the idea of especially
looking back in retrospect that
him
killing the guy who she had an affair
with
that was probably the thing that allows
him the sense of closure to be like come
in here like I inflict the trauma now on
you yeah
and then and then he's like and she's
saying I'm sorry and then he holds her
you know uh
yeah it's so it's probably in his mind
is is how retribution happens for the
situation yeah yeah oh
is is nasty
um
yeah but I still would have liked a
little bit of
a little bit of Retribution but it is
interesting it starts off like Affair
and how is this gonna like is this an
emotional turmoil that Center to this
point and I like that they didn't make
him a copycat but that he was the
original killer the whole time which
just makes the whole plot even more
ridiculous
it's a little that's a little silly it's
a little silly but I like it it's a
perfect crime like lead investigator is
the guy like okay like I can see why
that would work but it's also on top of
all these other circumstances yeah it
just feels so high concept it's like
lead investigator was the guy the whole
time yeah and that's a Saw movie thing
that's yeah that's what I mean it isn't
that it's it isn't that this guy snapped
because as I thought okay maybe he
snapped because of Affair and and that
and now he's become copycat guy you know
like is is that what happens but no
control all this time he's been the guy
yeah which just makes me he was like
sillier to me sure
sure and while you know he's got
compensate for being gifted this
beautiful house and this beautiful life
and you know he's got to feel like uh
he's getting control somehow yeah yeah
yeah uh yeah this this was yeah a really
fun and uh unfolding sort of experience
where like yeah at the top you're like
is this about to become like Blum House
hereditary or something and I do like
that at the end of the movie like yeah
you have the cheating element like they
set up all these very classic tropes of
like oh you know dad's trying to kind of
bond with the kid and like there's been
a marital Affair and they're just trying
to get along and so at first you're like
okay we're getting this kind of standard
issue drama to flavor this weird WTF
experience so yeah like at the beginning
it feels like a haunting movie or
something like that or yeah some kind of
weird strangers thing and so you're like
okay Bloom house meets a24's creep dread
Less in your face style but then yeah
the the it reminded me of multiple
movies definitely strangers and and
definitely like I said The Collector but
at the same time like the execution and
the ultimate like placed it landed felt
very kind of fresh and invigorating and
unique to this even though yeah and
prisoners is in there too like there are
so many things that clearly learn from
but I thought it made for this really
great ride that they really for the most
part it's like you know did he how did
he know that the boyfriend would get
there and then time his you know ride
with his partner to go get that file so
that he could kill him like they're
little things like that where I'm like
okay how does some of the logic work but
for the most part uh yeah the the game
of perspectives and just the ever it's
deepening hole of nasty sort of
psychology uh yeah just like I think
it's all kind of brought together by
that stuff it's like it's I I'm always
kind of open to and welcoming of a sort
of what the hell is happening experience
but it's up to the movie to know what
it's doing enough to bring all that
together to make that worth its while
and here I thought it was like here I at
the beginning of the movie or part way
through I thought okay this is this is
gonna feel like a a less fresh and
interesting Barbarian or something where
it's like you have this weird tension at
the beginning and then like a complete
uh reorienting of the stakes and
circumstances and all that and then
you've got this like balls to the walls
payoff whereas here like I thought it
really did nicely to again transcend
that you know comparison Point into its
own sort of Twisted journey to where
like yeah at the outset it feels like
okay this uh detective is trying to
figure out a serial killer case while
also being tormented in his personal
life uh but then at the end of the movie
you just realize like oh no the movie's
about this kid who escaped this guy's
clutches ultimately takes his revenge
and brings him down
and so like it's cool to start with one
line log line and end on a completely
different one yeah and I thought it was
neat too because the the movie did a
good job on selling me that he's a
psycho and I do appreciated that with
the frogging thing like part of me then
at the at that moment was like okay so
you read up on frogging and you're like
I'm gonna make a cool frogging horror
movie where people think they're going
insane is really just people living in
the walls but even that's been done and
so it's like it took a bunch of these
familiar styles of story they're all
very like in the Zeitgeist and managed
to build them into something kind of
Primal and classic but that also like
really nicely you know purposes those uh
you know kind of current elements in a
way that's very sort of satisfying and
still sort of current feeling that's
interesting on um I wonder why this
because this this article is from March
11 2022 does it have anything to do with
the movie I see you
I don't know maybe I mean no it's not
even mentioned in this article huh it's
a thing that like um yeah has been kind
of an Internet urban legend or there
have at least been reports of yeah
people living in other people I'm just
trying to I'm trying to see if like if
yeah no no I'm saying that it is for
this article to be published in March
2022 when this movie's it's number one
trending in March 2022. this is a
responsible third article low budget but
it's not but I'm saying like maybe
people are looking at frogging that led
to like them discovering this movie sure
like the concept of it I've heard of
like squatters I've heard the term
squatters and squatters doing this kind
of thing was like so there's all there's
concepts of squatters where you can't be
living secretly in your home or you
could just you know be dicks about it
but yeah this is like squatting with a
game element yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um I don't know who would document this
[__] I know that's the stupidest part of
the movie to me is like why would you
doc you didn't even need the
documentation side of it yeah I feel
like you could have just had them
recording just because it's like they
needed an excuse to that's part of the
weakest part of the scripting to me I
was like you you yourself are saying
this is illegal weekend so what are you
gonna do with this footage yeah and why
are you trying to disseminate it to help
other people do it too when that would
only kind of serve to like help people
recognize when it's happening yeah much
easier you're putting your face on
camera you're talking I'm like this is a
terrible idea lady why would you do this
you have a cell phone and everything
yeah keep the masks on and do it like
maybe and that could necessitate The
Mask a lot more than just sort of a
random Motif that matches the activity
yeah uh that was the silliest part to me
and it seemed like a part that they
included so that way they could have the
moment where the cop goes over the [__]
they don't be doing [__] in my house you
know when I'm like there's other ways
you could have gotten there yeah it
feels like something out of a VHS movie
yeah it was once there's a one part
because I thought other than that like I
liked the the actress a lot uh whoever
played the main Frogger I thought that
she she was great and I love this
situation that she was in I just I just
loved how it just kept getting stacked
which is more ridiculous I really liked
the last half I enjoyed the first half
and I really liked the last half a lot
the last half was yeah was when it gets
the it I feel like that's when it really
Embraces what I want to be and I feel
like it would make for a fun re-watch to
see if you could ever see these hidden
spots I loved how they play with the
perspective on you're going back to the
previous scenes that you saw in the
first half and you could see where they
were the whole time and it's believable
yeah that you couldn't catch them it's
it it's not it never the movie never
made me go how could they not have
suspected that there was someone living
there or how could they not have seen
they made that very plausible and how it
played out and I thought the way they
handled the reveals too was great like
like when the cop hit
um Sam from True Blood when he when he
did hit him in the basement with the bat
you know you it you're immediately
thinking it's the guy she's frogging
with yeah and then the way the camera
does the reveal the like from starts off
on the dead body and then pulls over to
the left you're like oh [__] yeah that's
the copy like sure oh this is wild did
he just kill him or is there something
to do without it has your mind going and
right up until the end and I thought
that was a lot of fun I thought they had
a lot of fun I would have liked the
result though because I have a very
clear plot because it's like you have
two plots in the beginning of this movie
you have the fair family situation right
there and there's someone stalking me in
this house what's going on at an
investigative mystery and then they kind
of completely drop the other one yeah
and I guess the movie's saying that's
resolved with the guy being dead and the
they made amends by hugging it out at
that moment you know yeah as the movie's
saying that's when it's amended and I
feel like there was a little bit more to
it that they kind of just dropped but
but I also do appreciate
they get someone like Helen Hunt in here
where like what is the poster for this
movie
um is it just her looking you know what
I remember I'm gonna play this at like
1.5 speech it's like super super quick
on my end the ICU trailer and just to
see if they like watch the giveaway like
did they lead with Helen Hunt in the
trailer I'm just gonna play like super
super Speedy just to get the visuals for
it but I'm not gonna play it on screen
um yeah 1.75 speed let's go through this
yeah they're mainly leading with the
first half and they're mainly leading
with Helen Hunt
um yeah yeah the sort of yeah yeah yeah
so I think that's smart like you leave
with Helen Hunt in the in your build up
and you feel like she's the main
character
and she's gonna be going through the
torture torture stuff is just happening
because of her so I think it's smart in
that way who's who's like it's more
impressive than I expected yeah I had no
expectations I was more like what's this
random movie trending yeah totally no
it's it's like tight and clever and and
it has that sort of disorienting quality
and it manages to earn that too yeah
yeah it snakes between being different
kinds of movies and uh yeah like there's
something about the way that they just
commit to her that does it's like the
two female characters in the movie
ultimately are sort of exonerated of a
lot of things even though they are you
know guilty of certain parts of the web
of you know uh mess uh and so yeah it's
like because Mindy dies and that's a
real bummer uh I feel like it could have
been nice to at least compliment of like
okay Helen Hunt lives and also maybe
we just get some kind of emotional
payoff for her because she has been so
manipulated throughout this whole
situation uh and and I mean Mindy has
been too to an extent I mean for
obviously better reasons but yeah
thematically it would be I guess it's
not in the movie's main concerns but it
would be nice to have and for this one
too like I don't know something other
than just like okay they're gonna come
home too an even worse yes subversion of
their entire lives What Becomes of the
sun who like already hates this [__] out
of his mom yeah and and who you know has
at least had some kind of uh comfortable
Rapport or some some you know Refuge
with his dad yeah you know who's now had
that taken from him
on top of being in a situation where he
thought he was being kidnapped by the
actual serial killer but he wasn't but
it turns out that that's his dad anyway
so he might as well
like there's there's a lot of
interesting stuff there and part of me
wonders like I could if this had done
better I could see how this could turn
into some kind of weirdo franchise but
but yeah I guess man it's getting it's
it's number one on Netflix sure no I can
random low budget ass movie that barely
made any money in the box office is is
like suddenly killing it and that's
really cool like it's cool to see it
yeah yeah it's cool to finish one of
these and be like wow like while this is
like the perfect Netflix movie because
too if you're watching your house is
gonna get you thinking about every
little sound you hear but also the kind
you would talk with people I think this
is the kind of movie you would be like
trying to guess with your buddies if
you're watching yeah yeah you know yeah
just wait just wait you won't be able to
put it together and and uh yeah it's one
of those movies it's like very
gratifying it's like people use the word
Hidden Gem a lot but I feel like this is
a good example of that it's like yeah
this didn't do huge when it came out at
first but I hope people start to talk
about it because this seems like it
should be it's good enough to exist in
the conversation with your recent
Barbarian and other things like that you
know Smiles or whatever else like I
probably I probably liked this in some
ways more than smile at least I would I
don't know if I would I don't know how
exactly it's a barbarian I think on
production
wise like there were parts of it
production wise that definitely felt
like
um like especially in the sound design
when it came to like dialogue moments
where I could where I felt a little bit
less like I don't want to I don't know
if the right words amateur is it amateur
film is I wouldn't say is more of these
sound is on where you could feel a sum
of it where this is still like big early
filmmaker you know whereas a movie like
smile sure is while that follows a
little bit more of a traditional it's
more Blockbuster even this yeah this
that I'm talking just on the filmmaking
side but if I were to learn like these
guys got another movie coming out it'd
be interesting to see how they step up
their game in terms of just the crafts
from inside of because they they go
crazy a little bit with like the
cinematography of these long drawn out
shots and going through the houses and
these overhead drone shots and a little
bit of these landscape moments and I'd
be curious to see like okay now how they
up it with their DP in the next one to
really just give it that extra Edge yeah
of not just like Saban films is that is
actually not bad company
and then sometimes they come up with
things that are extremely low budget
Lo-Fi you know and so once in a while
it's not the greatest thing or you could
tell this is very amateur filmmaking or
low bud or something that you know the
The Bargain Bin kind of example and in
the beginning I was going I guess this
is like right above that in the
beginning of this film I was like I
guess it's like right above there and
but then it became something much more
that I thought was actually impressive
and it did remind me of the days when
saw first came out sure you're getting
all this like influx movies of things
they call torture porn and this was not
that genre of what they even associate
with that genre but it kind of had that
like B-movie flavor well yeah yeah
kitchen sink pulls like all of the
different kinds of dread from all the
sort of popular subcategories and just
packs them into the same movies yeah
because yeah it's like you feel like you
are watching it you're watching a
psychological torture no matter which
way you're looking at it in a sense
because everybody's situation like no
one's situation is in a status quo or in
a state of uh you know just like
existing Beyond anybody else like every
micro uh relationship is experiencing
some kind of weird turmoil and then the
macro situation is even more messed up
yeah and uh yeah I would so what would
you rate before we look at Rotten
Tomatoes which I have not seen yet what
would you call what would you be your
percentage rating uh
like you know like a
7.85 wow 7.8 I was gonna say 78 that's
funny hey 78. yeah it's like pretty
solid I don't know see that's the thing
is I think but like an 18 is a b if
you're going by letter grade so I don't
give this one yeah like no I'm going by
percentages
is the majority of a hundred yeah it's
like pretty damn good rating
it is fun yeah no like I think if I was
on Rotten Tomatoes I saw a horror movie
had 78 this is pretty cool very good
horror movie I guess yeah yeah yeah
yeah
um I had a thought but it Escapes Me Now
I'm gonna I'm gonna click it I'm gonna
see Moment of Truth sure
whoa
whoa it's right I guess the tomatoes
yeah that's so funny yeah an audience
score not too far behind wow I had no
idea yeah
wow we were like we were pretty much
like right on the money we're a little
higher than them but yeah it's it's kind
of funny
what is that what is the consensus I see
you gets tripped up in its own narrative
contortions absolutely
put a solid gas and an effective blend
of scares and suspense makes the slow
building mystery worth watching
absolutely agree 100 yeah I just think
it's so funny how we were like right
right if we were lined up with Rotten
Tomatoes pretty well that's a solid
consensus right there yeah also just
real quick props to because you said the
thing about the sound and I was like
yeah part of it that made me wonder if
some of these droning uh score elements
were to cover up Let it give way to just
like crazy ass music that said really
like the music and I also thought that
like props to the location scout because
they got so much out of this house and
and the house also has to be able to
sell it so uh yeah as well well uh
conceived and yeah executed overall well
they didn't do too much exterior like
the wood stuff they did but that's I
feel it's kind of easy to find those
locations Main Street yeah in the car
the police station yeah
so they didn't really change too much
but it doesn't make it I don't become
like hyper aware that we're we have in
left locations that often like I would
just feel restrained yeah it doesn't
feel like they couldn't afford to leave
location yeah it's like it's so much
involved with this house and then when
you go like really far out and you find
like the the camper van where he's got
his you know kidnap victims like that
feels like it's really out on the
fringes of everything yeah
um yeah that was uh
that was a nice surprise yeah well done
America well done elevator
guys leave your thoughts down below what
did you think of ICU did you predict all
this stuff did you hear about it via
Netflix and watch it or have you heard
of this movie for ages
yeah what does the trailer even have
20s 1.4 million views three years ago
it's kind of crazy to see this movie
just [__] it's nuts I'm sure they
find it's awesome I'm sure there's like
I'm gonna type an ending explain I'm
sure there's like some big videos on
that
yeah I found foundflix has one from two
point that's 2.3 million views I wonder
if any of these channels maybe helped
really actually helped expand the
visibility for the movie because I don't
know there's only that one huge video
but at the same time that could be
enough to you know start that little
wave of people finally checking it out
and recommending it yeah because I could
I could definitely see this being a
movie people would want to talk about
I mean yeah I I to me when something
goes number one on Netflix I go
audiences must be enjoying this yeah
and sharing it guys leave your thoughts
down below and hey let's send this for
the pain
Chase Gardner come break into the studio
and live in the walls I think you you
know you're very active on the patreon
giving us support and whatnot you're
also very active here on the YouTubes
and I feel like you know if anybody
could create the right amount of tension
in life by moving things around but also
maybe leaving little things to encourage
us that would be you so you could get
your jollies off making us question our
own sanity but then you could also
reassure yourself that you're a good
person by leaving us things that will
enrich our lives somehow and then you
can also start your own channel teaching
people how to do exactly what you just
did to their favorite YouTube channels
and then everyone's helping each other
Thrive and succeed and then you can
start your own patreon and then get paid
to break into all sorts of other
people's houses so uh Chase
I don't expect any credit for this idea
just keep your pledge going and we'll
see you next month and every month until
you die in the closet over there love
you buddy
love peace
[Music]